we're going up to the lobby the global
lobby and Aaron hen for the BC
Children's Hospital dream lottery grand
prize draw
there you are Aaron excited thank you
Mark yeah we are so excited and we are
ready to do the big draw so grab your
tickets and yeah I just want to talk to
Jeff Parkin first he's a board member
from the BC Children's Hospital
Foundation and Jeff how much money was
raised for the dream lottery this year's
dream lottery made a profit of about 2.2
million that's gonna go straight towards
BC Children's Hospital Foundation
fantastic and it's the second year of
the lottery so what's the total this is
the second year of this lottery which
makes the total about 4.7 million for
this one we've actually been running the
lotteries for about 11 years and so the
grand total for both lotteries over that
period is thirty million dollars towards
Drona's Hospital Wow so a lot of kids
are gonna be helped all around our
province it's fantastic yeah so where do
the where does the money go to exactly
100 percent of the proceeds from the
lottery are going directly to childhood
research so it'll be towards things like
cystic fibrosis childhood cancer
diabetes all that stuff that's really
important for getting kids healthy in
British Columbia okay excellent
all right I think we're almost ready
here the winner has a choice of five
different prizes from a gorgeous estate
home in South Langley to another big con
our house in Fort Langley to a condo in
Vancouver or condo in Victoria or two
million cash so Jay are we ready from
knv accountants let's let's do the draw
here Oh
just thank you know somebody's gonna
have a good day today yeah I think so
what a Halloween it's gonna be and the
winner is the winning ticket number is
four two six three six four two and
that's Barry Delaney of Port Moody BC
congratulations congratulations Barry
we're gonna give you a call right now
and Soufan Squire I'll throw back to you
guys
Barry Delaney not very delay no no
actually and let's just take one more
look I think it's it's Barry Delhi I
think Delhi very Delhi
Dulli yeah well that's even closer is it
how does it spelled de le why that's
Barry no it's not seriously where's a
person lived
moody very easily lives in Port Moody do
it we'll look into it we're gonna call
right now hold it a second what did he
win give me the phone you're mine I'm
not gonna say his phone number on the
air hold on seriously forget this light
on the air on the air oh just wait a
minute okay get him on the phone - Fiona
is he allowed to win yeah I think so I
don't think there's a rule that says you
can't bury you know we're best friends
right
hey Barry come on the air they just drew
a name Barry delay for that house
lottery in Port Moody mm-hmm I'm not
kidding you bragged about this you guys
get hold it hold it Barret hold it we
want to put you on live here first okay
what is that what are we transform - p66
xtube give it to me you know what this
63 give me that hold on a second six six
83 Barry hold on hold on six six eight
three or what okay hold on this is weird
did you get it fee oh I hope so
are you there I'm shaking I was so
excited
so waiting show this the ticket again
okay
Barry are you there I'm here I'm here
okay show us the ticket are you looking
at the TV you know what I'm buying
groceries okay well in a second show me
show us a ticket again show us a ticket
with the ticket it has the address okay
hold on very good Street you know you
know people are gonna think this is kind
of fishy don't you sorry okay it's it's
a very delay important Moody how many de
le wise or import moody I think just me
you know congratulations you just got
groceries in a two million wendy win I
don't know you wanted two million dollar
house or son are you a little dream
about hold on you know it never comes
true okay okay hold it a second
we'll go to break I'm gonna check the
ticket for the address stay on the line
I will read you the address you don't
believe it huh do you know I don't I'm
sure I'm sure
yeah I always figured one of these days
someone was gonna win that we know that
works here one okay hold on don't go
don't go anywhere but can we take a
break buy a lottery ticket while you're
there okay
take a break I don't know what else to
say something about football this is
amazing well it was gonna be a sports
cast then one of the sports guys won a
house not just any house he could all
not just any sports guy be a condo yeah
was one of ours Barry delay nearing
alliances right now who was shopping at
superstore and then I phoned him and he
thought I was asking him what shift he
was supposed to work this week and
instead we're telling him he's won a
house and so are you coming into work
Thanks should I start looking for a new
sportscaster what's going on here well
perhaps maybe maybe I'll see you after
Christmas okay some guy just passed me
and said he heard I'd won so here we are
live on the air spreading viral I don't
know it's a house or like a choice you
get a house or a condo somewhere I'm
Vancouver or a condo and Victoria or two
million dollars I think or two really
dollars yeah you don't get it all I want
to win us good choices like that you
know okay here's the stupidest thing
just so everybody knows every week we
have a big pool buy a lottery ticket
right everybody in the sports department
in except for Barry he refuses to
participant so instead he goes and wins
the house I think we won ten bucks once
and he gets two million because saving
is too easy it's a good thing you went
on your own otherwise be splitting with
all of us that's right that's right no
it's amazing because you know what mark
history with Children's Hospital our
daughter eat in the head you notice with
leukemia seven years ago and we always
try to support the lottery and it's
unbelievable I just can't even I can't
think straight here that's all right
well I'm believable okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna read sports here because I still
have to work for a living okay really
yeah
I'll tell you what that's like
I'll get my people to call your people
later in the weekend all right enough
it's good to know it's good that rich
friends I think there's two point five
million fees that we you said oh it's
gone up yeah we invested it for a state
in Langley worth 2.5 million or two
million in cash or how much in cash
two million Gillian Wow I'm making 20%
of what Roberto Luongo is making this
year that is right either
that is good very congratulations
graduate much guys it's uh I'm just you
better phone your wife and kids like did
I tell them squire in the break I said a
little you know you always have that
little fantasy dream because I actually
had just got the tickets not too long
ago about this phone call and I don't
know if that made a difference or not
crazy stuff nice all right I'm glad I'm
the first to tell you you're married
Elaine he's rich when you kick Chris
galas words is a little anticlimactic
right now how much time do we got left
in sports like 30 seconds okay pretty
much that's amazing when he was at Barry
Delaney no it's buried delete no it's
buried delete yeah we've heard of that
guy yeah